du tabou existentialiste de 1952 au
théâtre de dix heures en 1962 le chemin
parcouru par pour réussir ou le même que
le vôtre celui de montmartre les a
conduits à une réussite exceptionnelle
et chaque soir monsieur chnops ont
remporté un véritable petit triangle
nous recevons chaque soir ici à notre
tribune une personnalité étrangère qui
vient nous exposer ses vues sur le
délicat problème de la liberté
individuelle
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand honneur de
céder la parole à monsieur alexandre
ch'nord ce cher monsieur chnops si vous
voulez bien si vous voulez bien d'entrée
suis heureux de vous accueillir si je
suis d'autant plus qualifiés pour
prendre la parole dans votre tribune que
j'ai quitté mon pays et que je viens
demander asile à la france
eh bien écoutez cher monsieur voyez-vous
sans avoir consulté qui que ce soit je
puis vous dire moi d'ores et déjà que
cet asile nous vous l'accordons et le
grand choeur croyez le bien
je n'en attendais pas moins de fou voilà
vous pouvez être rassurés vous avez en
quelque sorte choisi la liberté alors
j'ai selon la formule usitée choisi la
liberté
j'ai d'ailleurs l'impression qu'on peut
hélas de moins en moins vivre là bas
vous voulez dire qu'on ne peut plus
vivre du tout du tout du tout du tout
mais vous vous êtes échappée de russie
même où d'un pays satellites de suisse 2
je me suis échappée de suisse
c'est la première fois que j'en parle
dire ça ce ne sera pas la dernière j'ai
montré la voie d'autres suivront
mais qu'est ce qui a motivé votre départ
de suisse la tyrannie du régime
helvétique ps surtout surtout à bompas
que le régime helvetica et tyrannique
c'est à dire que toutes les libertés
sont réduites à néant tout simplement
nous vivons en vase clos
parlons un exemple quelconque vous
voulez respirer là bas n'est ce pas il
vient vous ne pouvez respirer que de
l'air suisse évidemment oui mais je
pensais à part ça qu'il existait une
grande liberté d'expression mon cher ami
liberté d'expression oui pour les
gentils sont dans la ligne qui se
contentent de dormir de travail et de
boire de manger de se distraire à la
rigueur mais pour les autres les autres
ceux qui aspirent à autre chose alors
pour ces gens là c'est l'étouffement
alors les adultes bien entendu se
résigne mais il la jeunesse monsieur
notre pauvre jeunesse
mais c'est le problème de la jeunesse
évidemment la jeunesse la jeunesse et
imprimer un le mal actuel de la jeunesse
ne pénètre pas chez nous la jeunesse est
muselée mais aucune fureur de vivre
aucun goût de la violence est cependant
monsieur cette jeunesse à la besoin de
s'extérioriser
elle a besoin de frapper d'un sommet de
tuer comme partout ailleurs
bah évidemment si on ne tue pas à 20 ans
et pas mais d'où vient cet amour fie aux
trios d'où vient cette mollesse à mon
avis d'une trop lourde hérédité de paix
ça alors écoutez franchement entre
nouveau en est bien content on ne dépose
pas les armes
pendant des siècles sans que la jeunesse
en soufre un jour ou l'autre allons
voyons une paix qui a fait un mal fou à
ce pays et à tous ses enfants mais
sûrement et puis alors chez nous vous
comprenez pas d'exemple pas de capitaine
pas de jeanne d'arc
personne n'a jamais bouter les anglais
hors de suisse ils n'ont jamais envahi
la suisse non plus il faut dire d'accord
mais enfin on aurait pu les provoquer ah
c'est certain nous n'avons jamais été
regard avec la france
non est-ce que c'était bien nécessaire
merci quand même ne serait ce que pour
favoriser un rapprochement c'était
nécessaire ne vous croyez moi chez nous
il y à une invitation permanente à la
paix mais c'est la paix froide sont j'ai
songé que notre pays vient de subir
trois grandes paix mondiale monsieur
sont des choses des choses auxquelles on
ne pense pas toujours mais évidemment
évidemment sont des choses qui comptent
t3 grande peine trois grandes paix en
quoi en 100 ans exactement prenez
l'exemple de mon grand père mon grand
père a fait 71 14 18 39 et 45 63 p 3 p3p
dans la vie d'un homme ça compte ça
compte quand même et il est toujours de
ce monde il a tenu le coup il est
toujours de ce monde où il vient de
s'engager dans la légion ajouté